previously on TV sins oh that sounds
like something a chicken would say bug
but nobody calls me chicken needles
nobody
it's enought this country's worse riot
with century show opens up with the real
horrific footage of a sensitive moment
in American history so I'm sure it'll be
handled with the nuance and grace of a
director who's known for such restraint
reading also seriously good does this do
for anyone that's unfamiliar to this
story to establish what year it is other
than a brief shot of a dashcam at the
beginning of that montage there's really
no way to know where we started I
remember the first celebrity I ever met
Willie Mays I was just a kid but it made
me go that's what I want to be when I
grow up
hopefully the limo driver is not
thinking the same thing oh hey what's
wrong
show tips it's hand on whether it's
gonna lean into reality or drama early
on what kind of a dumbass doesn't
immediately look over to where the dog
is intently staring and barking discount
Kevin James oh so we're just gonna enter
the house of a deceased person without
saying anything dude why even bother
clearing the rooms if this is the best
you're gonna do if it's too much to
handle alone call for goddamn backup
it's also gloves hat and envelope that's
our folks this is 102 critically
acclaimed TV shows from 2016 that
explored all the details that you've
heard many times before about this case
it was truly the Dante's Peak volcano
era of OJ crime stories also in case it
isn't clear yet we're sitting the out of
this show not the actual tragic deaths
of two people both of whom are
constantly overlooked when retelling the
story cluding this right here which
treats this event as a springboard for a
chance for some actors to work on their
impressions and bad makeup that OJ
Simpson may notify him yet we don't want
a Belushi situation and we don't want
Ryan Murphy all over the life and death
of John Belushi so how about we don't
give him any ideas Chris power I don't
think I've ever been up here before
clearly otherwise you would have driven
up to the gate in the driveway instead
of parking and half a block away to
allow a brief walk and talk hey you
should see this you better come take a
look at this cliche why don't they
answer the door in all of his career
have they never knocked on the door
someone who wasn't home this shouldn't
be so confusing lately ignoring
doorbells look I don't care how urgent
your need is in a house this big the
doorbell is gonna be a very obvious
choice
idolatry hey that's an actual sin also
why is this treated like a bump on Bowl
moment they know exactly who owns this
house are you on a substance
well show recreates every Thanksgiving
conversation I've had with my mother
this goes on for some time and I guess
it's trying earlier to establish the
doubt that we have about whether or not
he did it but it comes off more like a
bargain bin kubrick tracking shot you
didn't ask how she died look Joe we all
have opinions on this case I told Kate
Oh Caleb personally that Oh Jay did it
so showing me stupidly supposed gotcha
moments like these do nothing for anyone
and I guaran-damn-tee you it's the first
of many times in this series this show
is clearly attended the Fast and Furious
presents Hobbs and Shawn school for
titling things hey Travis that's all we
have kids no okay camera man what the
hell sort of wild ride am i taking here
I just want to see what kind of cereal
the kids are having because if it's
Cheerios that kid has a point about not
wanting to eat the lady you're gonna
wash those puzzle pieces down the drain
do you not know the gut-wrenching
disappointment of a missing puzzle piece
and a nearly complete puzzle can we
really trust Martha's opinion on
anything when she's forgotten to put the
milk away just one of the prosecutors
opinion that's all
well this prosecutor says go get him
this always happens in TV shows was
investigator done talking did you really
not need any other information could you
not say goodbye god this whole story is
gross it was gross in 1994 and it's just
as gross now adding a sheen of extra
drama to it both reminds you how gross
it is and adds to it so thanks for
giving me stomach cramps Ryan wins baby
shower oh Jesus sandwich a baby shower
on a lunch break on a workday I don't
care who Lin is or how sweet of a
miracle her baby is that's the dumbest
time for a party and it deserves to be
canceled what time you've all heard the
murder bruce greenwood isn't the
president of los angeles in this scene
Simpson has a prior five years ago he
pled no contest after he beat up Nicole
they've been specifically talking about
OJ doing crime in this meeting for quite
a while but this just now comes up fast
seriously is this the only [ __ ] to
put this puzzle together even my great
grandmother watching this on the Morning
News knew that was going down I've never
been a set designer before but can you
imagine getting the instructions for the
scene oh yeah we want the clothes to
spin around like at the dry cleaners um
you do realize that this will take
forever and we should really focus on
other I want a spinny closet also how
dumb is this idea what have a shirt
falls off a hanger would you park the
shirts like the Red Sea and crawl
through to Narnia just to retrieve them
sure I got nothing to wear while
standing in front of a packed closet
cliche what about lime green well I'm
good that would be exceptional except
they're gonna run out to never that
Michaels afraid of that color in case
the OJ isn't controversial enough for
you let's add some MJ also be sure our
reveling in the 90s nostalgia aren't we
maybe later someone with a Rachel cut
and talked about Jurassic Park and how
terrible the rock and country Superbowl
halftime show was look
I know your heart is in the right place
but these four walls they box you in
it's just an endless cycle
well Jessica Lange's conversations with
Ryan Murphy on the set of American
Horror Story something I'll make it into
this show see the way things are
sometimes money is the only way to get
justice this show can be over-the-top
insanely silly and outright terrible at
times but there are some damn fine
performances in this show and Courtney B
Vance and sterling K Brown might be the
cream of the crop this is outrageous I
agree a grown-ass woman should not have
a poster of Jim Morrison hanging in her
office yeah the tape is here person
walks into a room with the Declaration
and damning evidence and then we get a
dramatic you with a nice zoom in on the
interested party to end the scene cliche
Karen
Simpsons blood wait the spot head drew
OJ's blood back at the police station
then brought it all the way out to the
crime scene to deliver it to the
pathologist that's interesting because
it pisses me off when people talk about
themselves in third person
I'm sure he's saying something
interesting here but eyebrow can't
understand any eyebrow thing he's
eyebrow I don't want to be late we have
tickets to the premiere of I love
trouble said no one with excitement in
their voice in 1994 even Julia Roberts
and voltage it's OJ Simpson is this long
dramatic enough judges yes I'm being
told this is enough to marital rule
commercials I don't have time for this
honestly neither do i okay here I am
watching your lawyer question your
ability to handle the responsibilities
of being a mother and having a career
while also going through a divorce it's
great I am disgusted with how OJ
Simpson's been treated by the LAPD
especially after he did such a realistic
and sincere performance as one of them
in The Naked Gun films I don't think
he's holding up it's like he's not
really the juice anymore
well if he's juice he's not holding up
well at all because Jews Bob is right
just to give us something to talk about
mean if he's still free in two years you
could actually talk about something to
talk about so that's something to talk
about
Chloe stop running my god they included
that famous detail about the Kardashian
sisters being intimately involved in
this Oh Jay Simpson Storage gossiping at
a Funeral Municipal goona button in your
blazer before your bottom blesses the
bench well let's find him come on both
cops run in the exact same direction to
search this large mansion for the
potentially dangerous murder suspect do
you know
this is the last room Bob saw him in so
why didn't he check here first oh my god
we're going to look like morons
I get why you think that now Sarah but
don't worry come Awards time the show
will win HOH bleah 28 goddamn awards
show on 28 Awards is wrong with people
we don't want a Belushi situation are
you want a substance Wow
[Music]
this is a crime scene in this psycho
I smell bull Marcia yeah
Marcia Marcia Marcia putting off filing
until we get the blood test it feels
like bitten
nobody is more organized than bill I'm
here to help you believe that don't you
Danny that I'm here to help you in any
way I can bring isn't accepting the
proposed terms of divorce he wants to go
to trial god damn it you too old for
this